on continue à prendre notre bol d'air
avec la pointe la plus avancée de
l'europe qui va faire peau neuve il
s'agit de la pointe du raz dans le site
étaient envahies de commerces en tous
genres et de parking qui polluaient une
vue magnifique et bien ces commerces
vont être déplacés la pointe du raz
reçoit chaque année plus d'un million de
visiteurs on va y replanter la langue
qui poussait de tout temps naturellement
eh bien il en coûtera 40 millions de
francs c'est à ce prix que ce site
retrouvera son aspect sauvage jacques
devaux chaque boule est victime de son
succès la pointe du raz souffrent sous
le poids du tourisme
lalande passé le sémaphore n'existe plus
2 millions de pieds chaque année en sont
venus à bout recréer la végétation est
le premier objectif des essais sont en
cours
en canalisant les visiteurs sur des
chemins l'herbe devrait retrouver droit
de cité mais c'est surtout
l'infrastructure touristique qui est en
cause
les parkings et la zone commerciale
construite en 1962 seront détruits je
pense que vous en pensez mais je
porterai le port côté de l'émeute six
mois encore et ses grands parkings comme
ça la vue d'ensemble lorsque vous
arrivez se passait non moi je trouve ça
très bien dégagée tout ça en plus en été
c'est absolument horrible ici donc fait
marcher les gens c'est très bien à plus
d'un kilomètre de la pointe une nouvelle
zone commerciale sera construite elle
marquera l'entrée du site accessible à
pied ou par navette une construction
intégrés dont on a soigné la discrétion
garder le parking il a cité la wiz sur
trouve actuellement
ça voulait dire aussi que toute la
population aurait été sur une surface
très restreinte donc on n'aurait jamais
réussi à redonner à la pointe du raz
tout au moins les scènes pointe la
nature qu'elle mérite
une décision que les seize commerçants
du mal à accepter imposer aux touristes
de marché sur plus d'un kilomètre risque
d'en rebuter plus d'un distille
l'hôtel de l'iroise quant à lui ne sera
finalement pas détruit mais il devra
fermer noir au bout de 45 ans et bien
croyez moi que j'éprouve beaucoup
beaucoup de tristesse de devoir devoir
quitter tout ça comme ça pourquoi je ne
comprenais un budget de 40 millions de
francs devrait redonner à la pointe son
aspect originel il ne restera plus que
le sémaphore vigies indispensables d'un
passage maritime particulièrement
dangereux le rap ça